from a young girl with a big voice to a
young woman with an inspiring story and
a singing sensation who's ready to
finally take that top prize America's
Got Talent the Champions finale kicked
off with some seriously impressive girl
power performances eleven-year-old
Angelica Haile delivering yet another
show-stopping performance what does it
feel like when you get to hit those high
notes and then not only do that but
impress the judges
it's amazing literally I'm so so happy
not even Howie Mandel who chose Angelica
as his golden buzzer could wrap his head
around her dynamite vocals the song
lives up to its name you know impossible
you're only 11 years old
kechi the 29 year old singer who
survived a plane crash continued to
dazzle the audience and judges alike
after selecting kechi as his golden
buzzer simon cowell couldn't help but
praise her the champions final would not
have been complete without you
I believe that ABC has helped me blossom
into one something closer to what I'm
supposed to me ten years after Susan
Boyle first set the world on fire
singing this my dream in the sensational
vocalists returned to the stage to sing
it again
I immediately a standing ovation for the
57 year old songstress judge Simon
Cowell even admitted Susan's performance
had him doing some self-reflection I can
remember vividly how disgusting I was on
the day before he sang and then what you
did and what happened afterwards enjoyed
every second and I totally enjoyed being
in America thank you all so much
it was definitely ladies night on a GT
the champions but the fellows also
showed off their skills here's what
happened when danger artists duo deadly
games got the judges involved in their
act